[Music]
so
hi good evening everyone we will be
starting in 10 minutes
and we are currently playing background
music so if you can't hear it
please troubleshoot your audio settings
alternatively you can sound us out by
the chat module
if you are facing any technical issues
we will also shortly be running a poll
and your participation will help us to
shape the discussion tonight as well as
add to our research inputs
so please do participate if you can see
you in a bit
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
hi everyone we are gonna start in two
minutes time
so once again we are playing background
music at the moment
if you cannot hear it please reach us
through the chat volume
you can also reach us through the chat
module if you are facing any technical
issues and also a gentle reminder that
we will be running a poll shortly
and we hope you'll participate to help
us to shape the discussion tonight
[Music]
so
hello good evening ladies and gentlemen
my name is janine i'm from the design
singapore council and i'll be your mc
today
so hello also to everybody joining us
over facebook
if you if you'd like to join us on zoom
and participate in the poll and q
a please click on the link in the
comments
thank you everyone for joining us today
for the webinar two-hour city with love
this session is brought to you by design
singapore council
the national agency for design in
singapore in partnership with center for
livable cities
deloitte center for the edge participate
in design
the housing and development board and
the urban redevelopment authority
in support of the singapore together
movement
this event is also part of the national
design center's program lineup in
august and september which has a
thematic focus on singapore our home
so before we proceed i would like to
highlight a few housekeeping notes which
you can see on the screen right now
and once again if you encounter any
technical difficulties
you can reach us anytime through the
zoom check
function we thank you for your patience
and understanding if conditions turn out
to be less than perfect
during this webinar your audio will be
on mute by default
however we welcome questions at any time
during the session using the zoom q and
a function
when you post a question could you
please also state your name
where you're from and which panelist
you'd like to respond to your question
finally do note that the session is
being recorded as well
and with this i'd like to kick off
tonight's program
which builds on last month's webinar
that discussed
different definitions of livability in
singapore
tonight we are going to explore how we
can design and create livability
in our spaces experiences and
interactions
we'll also be launching our public
surveys for this project
at the end of the webinar so please stay
on till the end to find out how you can
add your voice to our research
i'd like to start by inviting mr marquis
executive director of
design singapore council to give us some
opening remarks
mark is a design thinking pioneer in
singapore having designed award-winning
experiences for the public and private
sector
as a design veteran with wide industry
connections
mark has brought the work of the council
to the attention of global design
leaders
he is an architect by training and he
was recognized by the urban
redevelopment authority in 2017
as the top 20 under 45 architects in
singapore
please welcome mark
okay can anyone see me
hi hi everyone um uh good evening
just uh welcome uh welcome to our
webinar
uh um just thank you for dialing in
a warm welcome to our webinar to our
city with love
this is the second part of our two-part
series as
exploring what a lovable singapore means
to us
so i mark as janie has shared i'm the
executive director of the design
singapore council
and i'm super happy to welcome such a
wonderful and diverse audience from
singapore and also beyond our shores
i understand that actually this evening
we actually have guests from southeast
asia
india australia and various parts of
europe as well
so just thank you for joining us this
evening whatever time zone
you're calling in from a number of our
guests may be joining us for the first
time so i'll just take a few moments
to introduce design singapore council
and what we do
as a national agency for design our
vision is for singapore
to be an innovation driven economy and a
lovable city through design
we help organizations and enterprises
use design as
a strategy to grow businesses and
deliver people-centered public services
nurture industry-ready talents and
enable a design-minded workforce for the
future economy
we also promote the singapore brand
through raising design appreciation on
home ground
and making emotional connections with
people across the world
for example through this webinar tonight
i'm really excited to introduce the
topic of our webinar today which is
about how we can come together
to design a lovable singapore this
follows on from a wonderful discussion
we had from our first webinar
where our moderator and panelists
actually drove a very candid discussion
around what love means and how it's
defined and three
key questions arose from that vibrant
discussion
the first was what is singapore's vision
for lovability
the second who participates in creating
this vision
and who has been left out and perhaps
the crux of the issue which our guests
also asked in the q a
the last question was why is loveability
important to singapore
well our understanding of these issues
continues to evolve as we gather more
perspectives i would like to put forward
our thoughts especially for the third
question
why we are interested to study
loveability in singapore
from early research and interviews we've
done with our partners we've found that
people actually do
form strong emotional connections with
the places and communities they live in
and that there's a strong correlation
between emotional attachment
commitment and participation
so that is to say what we love we will
look after well
so in singapore examples of this have
been told
about through our interviews places like
community gardens
some void decks corridors about hp flats
public parks hawker centers and some
heritage sites
these are places of high lovability that
people feel strong ownership and
connections with
and they often speak about them with
pride and they may be motivated to keep
them
well maintained through our interviews
we found
that there are also of course places in
singapore that not so lovable
some interviewees brought up certain
heritage sites saying they feel
contrived and touristy what makes one
heritage site feel
authentic and lovable and the other
distant and irrelevant
this is the question we hope to explore
in today's webinar can we actually
design
lovable places and related to that can
we also improve places that aren't
lovable
and may even cause us heartbreak
[Music]
the answers to these questions are
important not just to singapore but also
to the world
for today more than half of the world's
population lives in urban areas
and by 2050 two-thirds of the global
population
will do so according to the united
nations
along with that cities are facing
increasingly complex
problems like climate change aging
population
economic recession as a result of
geopolitical uncertainties
and not to mention of course the severe
consequences
that a global pandemic has had on our
urban society and economy
we feel strongly that the solutions to
these challenges will be driven by
people who
love the places they live in and who
actually have a stake in improving the
lives of the communities and environment
so today we're excited to gather five
people from diverse backgrounds across
private public and community sectors
but who have all spent much of their
careers thinking
and working on creating loveability and
more importantly i'm sure
our speakers tonight will agree with me
we are keen to hear from you
our audience through the polls and
question and q a
in fact at the end of today's seven
webinar we'll be launching our public
surveys
to invite everyone to give us your views
on what is lovable
or unlovable about singapore and how
we can actually make singapore more
lovable
we're planning many different ways you
can participate in and share your views
through interactive activity
interactive activities and we welcome
all voices
our vision or lovability in singapore is
one that all of us
participate in and has a hand in
creating
and with this i would love to hand the
time over to our panelists
and i wish everyone of course a very
lovable evening
thank you thank you mark
and with that let's move on to tonight's
program please allow
me to introduce our speakers starting
from our moderator mr adam jalal
adid is an urbanist exploring how to
make our cities
lovable places for people to live in he
is the co-founder and director of
placemaking studio
shophouse and co where he consults on
strategies for community-centred
urban developments facilitates
stakeholder engagements
and curates programs to create a shared
experience of the city
joining him today we have four wonderful
panelists
first mr thailes yang is a practicing
architect and urban planner
whose projects have won both local and
international awards
he's a thought leader and a strong
advocate in the field of design
he is currently the executive director
of build sg
the building and construction
authority's industry transformation
initiative
next we have miss soli shan vishan is
the co-managing director of
agency her experience spends designing
for behavioral change
service experience design organizational
design
new product development and
communications strategy
as a journalist and design researcher
she believes empathy is at the root of
great design
and is particularly interested in
humanizing complexity
next we have miss hannah harris since
march this
year hannah has been appointed the chief
design officer
of the city of helsinki which is the
first city in the world
to hire a chief design officer being
devoted to being a design driven city
prior to this hannah was director of art
info finland
and she has also been program director
at helsinki design week
and the finnish institute in london
last but not least we have mr calvin
calvin has close to two decades of
experience in architecture and
conservation
at the urban redevelopment authority as
director of conservation management
he is experienced in managing public
education and
partnership programs overseeing place
management
efforts on a personal front kelvin loves
getting involved in his community
through grassroots projects related to
education
and intangible cultural heritage
welcome all speakers and now over to you
adi
hi good evening everyone once again
thank you for joining us this evening
from wherever you are i really
appreciate you spending your
uh evening or mornings with us
uh and like what's been introduced i
think tonight or this evening we're just
gonna
have a conversation about this idea
loveability right and as the
tina turner song goes what does love got
to do with cities
so so that's something i'm going to try
and explore a little bit uh we have
great
panelists joining us this evening uh
four of them
um and just before i go into that i just
want to remind everyone that we actually
opened a poll earlier just now
so there's a poll that all of you who
are listening in uh can participate in
and later i'll get back to that and see
we'll probably discuss where the
findings about what all of you feel
about the idea of a liveable city
so that's that um all right so let's
jump straight into it yeah
so just to give you a context uh the
first webinar that design singapore
organized talked about a very conceptual
understanding of livable
livable city right so there's a very
robust discussion
uh that video is slapped on on the
various design singapore channels
um and before this session uh we've met
the speakers
separately and we asked them uh to think
about that question of what does a
livable city mean to them right what
does it feel like
and everybody came back for court so as
the moderator i will start with my own
court
which is a city that holds space for
everyone
and learns all of the citizens back it's
the kind of city that i want to love
right a city that really includes
everybody no matter your
race language religion your abilities
your wealth
and no matter you have differences by
this city whole space for you
and i think that is the mark of a city
that i really want to love
so that's me but enough about me i think
let's hear from the panelists
uh there's four of them uh let's see who
wants to start first
like what does a livable city mean to
you what does it feel like
does anybody want to start
i did lisa i'm here i'm happy to start
sure let's go so uh the code that i
offer is what
we love we will sustain so
when i was asked this to participate in
this i
instantly of course brought up the book
that
my wife valerie and i co-wrote called
cities of love
back in 2016. and interestingly
um it was called cities of love but it
wasn't really about love
at first it was about sustainability
because i was chairing the world green
building council
and we were pondering how can we get
people to sustain
their environment their society and
economy so
and we discovered that one simple trick
would do it that is
if they love the cities they will
sustain it
so when we talk about cities of love i
really felt important to know
the reason for loving it because yes i
mean it's easy to say
express your love regardless of reason
but frankly i think at the end of the
day people need a reason as well
especially on the topic of cities and
environment
so then we think that it is important to
look at cities of love to then leading
to sustaining
the whole city itself that's my take on
it
hello if uh good evening hannah harris
here hello from helsinki to singapore
from helsinki the finnish capitola city
among many other cities but a city
that i call home and love very much uh
thank you for the invite and i would
like to
continue on what ty lee chung said about
that
connection with love and sustainability
um when when we're looking towards the
future of our cities of course
um a love for a place is one of those
essential ingredients in making sure
that we will care for that place for the
future as well and
invest different levels of care we can
discuss today what what that might mean
but
but essentially there that it it that is
like the core
ingredient for making sure that that
cities will thrive
in in different forms in the future too
thanks for that lis young and hannah i
think those are
starting points right this idea of
linking or a trick question at least
young queen right right looking love and
sustainability and realizing that oh
you're all so intertwined
and and it gives a reason i think they
will come back to that right do you need
a reason to love
um i i'm quite sure we're going to come
back to that so let's hear from the
other two speakers
i'm quite hi i'm quite happy to go next
um mostly because i don't want to go
last
sorry kelvin uh what's great to me
everyone
thank you all for tuning in tonight i
think my
answer of what a livable city feels like
to me is um
livability is the feeling of being
nourished
a livable city is one where people feel
welcome and
embraced for who they are and inspired
to grow
so my experience is designing um
for the large scale by actually focusing
on the human scale
so what does lovability look like when
it's made tangible
a livable a lovable city feels like
there are spaces within it that
i can make my own like for example that
i built beyond the functional so for
example i can bet a lot of money that
changi airport is the only airport in
the world where people go to study
in where tons of students go to study in
and make their own memories
so from a human-centered point of view
when it comes to lovable how do we
design for memories to be made
how do we better understand people's
aspirations and make them feel as if
those aspirations are understood
so that's how i'm thinking about
lovability today
that's wonderful leshan i mean the idea
that you know making your own right
um your own memories right i think
kelvin you have something about
your own memories and stories you have
something about that don't you
hi everyone uh good to meet friends from
here in
far i'm calvin um calling in from
kyungbahru
that you may know my quote is that
i love my singapore because there are
buildings and places
that remind me of human stories from the
past
so they anchor me right and not just me
and i love my hometown
because there are places and spaces that
actually seed and sustain human
relationships for tomorrow i think
if we want to have a sense of love as
someone said there's a factor of time
and there's also a factor of time ahead
hope because you want the seed to grow
right so so i don't think we we can
really uh
um just say love something that is uh
physically beautiful that's an emotional
angle and this
love is nurtured over time uh maybe it's
been like
arranged marriage perhaps right you you
have to do what you do with it
and and my anecdote um about loving a
place has
got to do with uh kampung glam my day
job
has to do with managing kampung lam the
history district in the north of
singapore
city and uh mark mentioned a bit about
people feeling an area whether it's
authentic or not authentic do they love
it or not
and and working with kampung glam has
actually given me some some insights
about
what makes it lovable interestingly
there's always an insider view and
outside of you
what makes a place seemingly authentic
may be very different from what makes a
place meaningful to the local people
right so by meeting the people um in my
life
who have all connections come from um i
realized that
they still love it simply because
they've got all those memories from
their childhood
and every time they go back no matter
what change that has been on site
not just about recognizing the buildings
that are there it's let's say
this is where i grew up this is where my
grandmother settled when she came from
java or from
sumatra or somewhere and when i go back
now i can still remember my own family's
story and there are people there who
know me
so this has been quite critical the idea
of this kind of
knowledge of each other and self over
time and therefore a sense of stability
right so so the kampung gun for me has
gone from a place that i go there to buy
batiks or rings or
collectibles to a place where i know
kampung gum is important to
uh my neighbor in queenstown because
auntie fatima
grew up in bosnia street and my friend
from junior college because
aoia's mom also grew up street they
never knew each other
but when they knew i did this work
suddenly say oh gosh you're looking
after our hometown
so starting the the response becomes
very very great so
it makes me as a planner i understand
that whatever i do the hardware
what is important for my constituents or
my
citizens that i work with as citizens
it's a software
what do i do to sustain that sense of
stability
that familiarity in the face of
inevitable change so love has to grow
but love needs a certain stability how
do you deal with this
change in stability yeah i mean
that's a very difficult question to
answer right and hopefully we can have a
chat about that
this evening that you want stability one
time but yet
we need to design for it and we have to
deal with this
you you mentioned this inevitable change
that's gonna come right whether it's
physical change or people moving out
um at least i kind of gave us a clue to
say oh maybe we could
potentially be designed to make memories
whether
um remind ourselves the past memories or
perhaps create new ones
so there's a lot of things that we're
going to unpack a little bit more
so before i move on i just want to
remind the audience we're going to close
the poll in about the next one minute so
if you haven't done the poll
uh please do so now um so back to the
panelists right
so we've we've kind of spoken a lot
about your personal perspectives about
this idea of a livable city right these
are your own personal
uh views or perspectives but then
for us to actually design one right we
almost need to have
i don't know some form of con do we need
a consensus
about defining what love is or
and who gets to define it right it's
such a big
word that it's easy for us to say but
how do we put it in tangible terms
yeah maybe one of you may have had some
experience in dealing with making it
tangible i don't know
somebody wants to talk about this
definition of love
wow that's that's a very difficult one i
as an architect gave up trying to design
human behavior
uh it's much easier it's much easier
design physical environment
no i did tell i did this point is that
in
in singapore we we always build the
infrastructure first
and then build the community whereas
i've been to many parts of the world
where you don't
they don't have the resources to build
infra so they actually build community
first
so i think it's contextual um
but back to these elements of love i i
to me the one thing i want to bring out
is that in designing the environment
actually one thing we take for granted
is safety
security sense of security you can't
feel love in a place that you feel
danger all over the place
so that's one place to start analyzing
what makes the place safe
and of course you can think about
physical attributes of a safe
environment
but on the other hand human being plays
a big part in a safe environment
i mean if you walk into a city that
everybody has
kind of kind eye contact with you and do
smile at you
and offer help even as a stranger i
think that's step one
but i've been to cities where nobody's
smile
i've been to cities where i look lost
nobody come and help me
so i can't tell i can't say there's a
cities of love
i don't know whether it helps but i
think just food for thought
yeah thanks for sharing at least yeah i
mean there's an interesting idea right
that
uh the cultural context like play is a
very important role i think we brought
up an example about how singapore have
always started the hardware
um and in other parts of the world they
start the heart first right
i'm just curious hannah what's your
experience with the build environment
and that link with the idea of
liveability
in helsinki how does it look like yeah
hi
um maybe i could tell about the example
of the
new order central library here because i
think it connects to many of these
themes and what leshon saw was saying
earlier about
i very much agree with that um potential
that we have
have to find the human scale in what
even are we designing something small or
large but the human scale within and
something that
allows us to grow and be curious and at
the same time there's a safe
safe kind of base or or kind of a place
that
is one's own and if if
i could maybe have the um already slide
on there now i could briefly tell about
the
story of um the new central library odi
in
helsinki which opened just under two
years ago
uh here it is the building by all our
architects and um
just to give you a brief context so here
we have like a large
major public um in fact we can stay on
this image for a second so
a large major um new built um
built environment invest in investment
in the city center of helsinki
this is in a spot which is um
symbolically
uh very very important so it's facing
the parliament building
so there's like the kind of the power of
the people are with the power of the
state so if you look at the top floor
balcony you stand there your eye level
is eye level with with the parliament
looking across
across the road but so this is a
building that came out
it it is of course now like a crown
jewel it's winning prizes design prizes
architecture prizes
what not it's uh it's um it's a kind of
a
very visible thing in injection into the
city center
but what's important there if we if we
look on to the next slide
so this if i can have the next slide but
yes so this is a building that
um was a much wanted um
like a we were kind of missing a central
library we as a nation have a hundred
years of history of
of building in a way the nation's
identity
with libraries this is a project we
explored as well in the
last venice architecture biennale but in
a way you can see here
there's been children's departments in
every library there's been this um
mentality of of pushing education
forward pushing something that is
a place for shared learning and a place
for everybody to make
make their own kind of in a way and
materialization of democracy and
and active citizenship but in this build
the case for this building so there was
a lot of work that went behind it
both with our library system and
so in a way those communities that are
using the library
it was a really a pilot for public
participation in all kinds of there was
lots of different co-design going on in
both
what a library of the 21st century might
mean but also how it functions today so
there's different kind of tale
organizational models going in there and
a lot of work in
making sure there was ownership in all
kinds of level from top management all
the way down
to different user groups throughout the
project of course it is also a showcase
of new finnish architecture it was um
it came out over at the time the largest
uh
open architectural competition in
finland well over 500 entries
and it was an international competition
but the uh contemporary office called
allah architects one
won this um so we got the um of course
this is part of helsinki's library
system so the cities
uh but of course it's also sort of it
plays a double role of being the cities
and
national and hence there was both
national funding and city funding that
went into this building but what's
really important in this
place if i can have the final slide
please
is that um you might think that there's
this sort of crown jewel
and and uh investment in in really
something of quality that
does that suck something away from the
small local library scattered across the
city so in helsinki there are close to
40 of them but no on the contrary we've
seen
a 140 percent increase in visitor count
in all libraries across the city
so a system that we kind of as a nation
have have loved and used throughout
different kind of
demo demographic groups uh that sort of
love
got uh that there really is that sort of
love of libraries that got sort of
uh amplified through this this crown
jewel
in the small libraries as well they've
been in this building so last year 2019
well over three million visitors and
also the amount of new library cards
registered has
has been phenomenal so i mean this
building it's basically three floors you
have the
ground floor is sort of the extension of
the public sphere there's all kinds of
information activities going on top
floor is the more sort of
library place with a very sort of
dignified uplifting feel to it and the
middle floor is about learning and
sharing together and very modular but
for me like it was something that
stemmed for
from our cultural strengths it was
relevant both
locally and nationally and
internationally has been
but importantly it has given back to the
community and at all scales so it has
been really become a place that's loved
and an icon of a system that's loved
yeah thanks for sharing that hannah i
think this example i mean
what i'm hearing is that i know there's
a shared love for for a reading that's a
shadow for
for for this book culture right the
library culture the the public spaces
it's a
gift back to the citizens um and i'm
also curious
or rather very interested in that point
where you say that it's almost a
symbolic gesture by the city to say that
hey this is going to sit in a site of
power like you mentioned right smack in
the middle of the city and has
even been given back um to the citizens
to enjoy
and that's almost like a stand that you
take that this is the city living its
citizens back
yeah so so that's something a point that
i want to bring up uh
like um it's kind of a a gift for
everyone on necessity for everyone that
everyone deserves this place that is
open to all and that
has principles of good design running
all the way through the process to the
end result
yes yeah i think that's something that
we will come back to that but i'm just
going to come back to this
uh section of defining it right um
yes we've heard about the cultural
differences uh both from from lisia and
also from from hannah
uh kelvin how about what about the rest
of us
how how can all of us define it right
who gets to define it what are your
thoughts on this
hi um
behind me are two pictures that i really
like
about singapore on this side is a
public portrait of book key or the
iconic sets of singapore city by one of
the early artists and on my
left is a watercolor of the kallang
river singapore's other river that's uh
unfortunately very uh overlooked
right but they've both been captured by
artists so
i've always thought that um our visual
artists be
painters drawers photographers etc they
have a special skill
to be able to crystallize a certain
sense of beauty
in our surroundings such that we re look
at our city and understand its complex
beauty so i think
one way of defining the beauty of a
space and perhaps therefore
triggered a sense of of affection and
love um would be to engage more
artists um including poets and
songwriters etc
right then the question is are there
some places that are really so unlovable
that no one would draw them
et cetera you know and that will
overlook it or they have no potential to
be left
but then there's a danger to focusing on
beauty does it mean that if something is
not conventionally beautiful
is therefore unworthy of being loved
um and i think this is something that we
have to think about
um so i thought the helsinki library
what may be interesting to to understand
would be that
does everyone who goes there to see do
they actually love
its look okay as a designer i says that
visual outcome is right is one of the
important
considerations or actually is this
something beyond
the the look or the visual appearance of
the library or the city
that triggers um the sense of affection
or wanting to love it
you know are there some other uh
mechanisms in it at play for example uh
we talked about it myth and myth making
are there some myths
of our various cultures that can
actually be very powerful
in either driving a design process or
design outcome
or driving the desire to want to love is
there is there a myth that you you feel
your boy has that that'd be i know that
there's a seat or something there that
we could
build upon and say that's the seat you
know moon is ideal ability lovable city
okay um okay so i was born in 1972
and interestingly on the same in the
same year uh the malayan was
inaugurated at singapore river right and
as i grew up in singapore
the malayan has been a figure that i
think is both loved and hated
it's a question is it for us is it for
others is it
uh what is this marriage of the the
lion city and the sea you know it is a
very powerful symbol
singapore's lion city uh but very often
i notice we no longer cause of the lion
city we are very practical in singapore
and we are we are city by the sea so uh
the malign is one outcome of trying to
create a new symbol for this line city
that's dependent on trade exchange of
ideas people coming everywhere for their
fame and fortune and
love i suppose right so so we have this
malign that
has been sitting there kitschy and all
that but recently i noticed that
the malign has become reinvented by
many different young artists in
singapore into objects that are not
for foreign consumption but for local
consumption for our children as self
toys as
key rings etc um so i think it's quite
interesting
are we finally learning to love the
malayan um
does it mean that in a hundred years
time we may one day have a ritual like
what they have in venice
every year the mayor of venice goes into
the harbor and throws a gold ring the
lagoon
to renew the vow of marriage between
venice
the lion city with the sea which brought
it as well
so perhaps so leeshan do you love the
malayan
i actually do love the it's actually
quite fun and i think a bunch of the
really interesting initiatives like for
one time there was this
hotel that was built around the lion and
it kind of sold out in an hour
or something like that like spend an
evening with the head of the lion in the
room
um in this like kind of tiny box around
it
and people just wanted the experience
and uh you know you see
lots of people i mean even the lion has
become part of the lingo
when you spend the night at the club and
you drink too much
you merlion um and that
and and i love how you know that they're
all these
kind of uh it obviously the built
environment overflows into common
vernacular
and people take ownership of the the
of the of the different structures and
the different things that have been
built
and make it their own and co-op their
meaning to something else which is why
i like moving on to perhaps my why it's
important to have a lovable city
and i love the analogy of love here
because it's ultimately an
outcome right it's an outcome of having
a common language
as an outcome of having something that
we
share that we have in common and that we
all accept
and take responsibility for so when i
say that people take
ownership over even the weird kitsch
things um
we feel emotionally invested in the
success
of of singapore so to speak right not
that's a big jump from the merlion but i
was talking about
a kind of love and what it means if
and like we all know that love works
best when it's reciprocal
right so i feel loved by my city because
i feel value
and i have a place and that my voice
matters so when it comes to who gets to
define
um uh who gets to define love
i actually think and i will shout out
for the industry i work in which is the
practice of human human-centered design
right it's that that has to start with
the user right the
end like your the citizen is the
customer
right and they have to be spoken to in a
way that
uh that has their aspirations heard and
how do we design for that so i think the
idea of you know we've done a bunch of
work
um over the last decade or so where you
know the
the needs of customers and citizens
become the foundation and common
language for anything that needs to be
designed
and that can be anything from a
government policy
to like a finance policy to a mall
and you can use those same principles
and that power bringing everyone to the
table
because we have distilled what those
needs are and what we need to design for
i think it's a great way to make someone
feel hurt
and as a result feel loved can i just
add a point
responding to kevin's point about his
love
must love be centered on beauty i think
this is where we need to distinguish
between
cities of love a lovable city versus a
lovable building
i think a city comprises of many
buildings some of many parts
so you can't avoid having ugly buildings
but on the whole i think you can have
beautiful cities just like human beings
right
so i i would subscribe to the view that
the
whole city actually all look beautiful
i've been to so many cities 50
60 cities and from the air most of them
look beautiful
the only time when you can say it's not
beautiful when they're so
badly maintained it is so unloved by the
people the physical building then you
know something is wrong in there
and i also make reference to hannah's
example in the library i think to me
that is a classic example of building
something by the city who
love the citizen providing the
infrastructure of that
beautiful building that becomes a
shelter for its people
and it doesn't work on its own it work
as part of the whole city
as a total environment of love
reinforcing
what the city leadership wants to do
wants to show to its people
so that's a classic example of what i
mean by building the hardware
but taking into consideration the
hardware
but my view is that you need both and
it's sometimes
easy to build something uh in response
to people
than to build nothing
and so here we are and talk about idea
of a tangible aspect
of this idea of a lovable city right i
mean at least you mentioned something
that
has a different to a livable city and a
lovable building and
and there are certain things that we can
design for and we can provide for
intentionally create the conditions or
the spaces or the buildings for that
and some maybe it's it takes a different
dimension
right so at this stage i think i just
want to lean towards that a little bit
right so how can we tangibly show that
we love the city and the city can
tangibly
show that it's loving us back because
it's very easy to say yeah i wish my
city loved me back
oh i love my city i might buy a malayan
plush
toy right but yeah but is that really an
act of
loving the city yeah right so yeah what
are the tangible acts that
you know policy makers and designers can
do uh maybe i want to start with hannah
um yeah one of the sound that enabling
acts of the city that that can be done
to show that it's leveling citizens back
well i think something was said there
earlier that relates to this crucially
is that
feeling of being heard and
i mean this relates of course to entire
systems about
how uh city services work or how
different feedback systems might work or
how uh the planning system works and and
so forth but
uh but then there is that sense of okay
my idea and my spot or something that's
important to me in the city
that how does that actually do i get
some response to it whether or not it's
being executed but that feeling of being
heard is crucial and um and that that
means that anything that's been designed
in a city
has to as as lee shan was saying start
from from that understanding of
why are we doing this in the first place
and for for who
and of course it's obvious that in a in
cities are complex things there are
different agendas and different kind of
wishes uh there won't be
one idea of how someone might feel loved
and cared for in the city
but that sense of of being heard
or that your your view matters somewhere
is um
is of course crucial and that's kind of
you know in housing for instance one of
the strategic aims is that there is that
element of dialogue and participation
and and being part of something how how
that can be developed in different ways
one one
um key area of course is for instance
how we
work with children and young people how
uh how you might in things like school
environments
incorporate into the curriculum uh for
instance if you're looking at the city
and it's the built environment that how
might you have something that
first of all uses the immediate
environment the school building or the
parks around the public space around
as a kind of learning environment and by
understanding more of the different
historical layers or what happens there
how how they came about
what the materials are where might they
go that sort of all contributes to the
what what they might be in the future
but but i i really believe that those
are strong elements
like was said earlier of giving us tools
to build our own places and those
memories
and and through that and appreciation
and will to want to contribute to them
in
in the future too
how about you as a designer i mean
you've heard that hannah was sharing
about participation about dialogue and
allowing people to feel that they uh
they are heard right whatever opinions
or ideas
given to them they are able they see the
change around them
right so there's a very tangible way of
of uh showing that the city is listening
to you as giving
itself and and investing in this
relationship
what about you from a design perspective
are there things that we can
tangibly do or we can tangibly impact
that
is hey this is an act of love
well when i was thinking about this i'm
like okay what does livability look like
when it's made tangible right and i had
talked
a little bit earlier about given the
tools to make your own memories and
create
meaning for yourself and i keep thinking
i think about that in terms of
why spaces should not dictate what we
can
and cannot do right so um
so i like to think about this as
designing to 70
and the idea of being heard is not
necessarily you raise your hand
or you put or you write something down
the feedback form and you put it in
right um i think there's so many ways in
which
people and i think about um
okay let me i've got one example which
is around
our mrt stations right and
uh which hannah that's our public that's
our public transit
um that's our subway basically and i
remember
uh a while back someone took the made
puns
out of all the station names so if you
google if people google singapore mrt
station named puns
you will see that there was this great
ground up initiative where everyone was
making fun of the was what was co-opting
the different station names and making
them into
into uh into really funny uh
singlish puns but then you also see how
are people using the mrt station today
in a world where
in a world where actually we should be
using less and less cars
right and people are only complaining
about how the mrt is breaking down
because they're using it for very
functional for a very very functional
purpose
but actually if you look if you went to
any mrt station you see that it is a
gathering place
for use to trade k-pop cards it is a
place where carousel transactions take
place over the gantry
it is a place where people have actually
started to make their own and then there
was one
law that was passed i'm not sure whether
it's still i'm not sure whether it's
still enacted or not
where they made transactions over the
gantry illegal
and you go that's an example of not
being heard
and i'm sure there was a very very um
specific reason for that law to be
passed
right but on the other hand it is people
living their life
and doing and going about their day and
doing their business
and uh and you know using the entire mrt
system
as uh as kind of their shop
to go go around selling things right and
i think about all the stories i love
the i love the so on the other from the
other point of view i love the
uh the library in finland and made me
think about all the libraries in
singapore
we have a wonderful very modern building
uh
in the cbd but we also have the oldest
library in singapore
which is in queenstown which has this
beautiful architecture that a lot of
people have a lot of memories
going to so what's the small and what's
the big
right how do you design for the small
and the big how do you design for
contrast
i think singapore as far as the built
environment goes
actually but you know uh how do you
combine both
how do you appreciate that grit
but as well as appreciate what should be
bigger
and grander and both have the ability to
provoke
uh to evoke not provoke evoke love
in us and i think those things have to
be taken into consideration
uh when we start to design for for
lovability
an idea of scale there something that
maybe the architects in the room
you want to say a thing or two about
that
hi kelvin here um oh lisa you want to go
ahead first
well yeah okay um now when you talk
about citizens loving the cities part of
the reason for the book was to uncover
stories about citizens loving their
cities
outside singapore actually at that time
i didn't think that i'll find enough
stories in singapore
so vancouver 2020 plan was exciting one
where the mayor started greening
vancouver by 2020
so one of the things about discovering
citizen section was that they
said to all the population in vancouver
tell me your story and we're going to
post it on a google map so everybody can
find your story
much to their surprise thousands and
thousands of stories start to be sent to
there and
shared with everyone so when i came back
and we decided to start an award called
the cities of love award
just to uncover stories in singapore
where ground up activities
truly citizen ground activity that show
their love for the environment
and please to say that every year we
discover about 20
very good stories just to share one
particular one with you
oh there this camera is not going to
pick up
okay let me i see a garden yes this is
okay sorry about it uh let me just
verbally describe to you
i think the virtual background is poison
now this is actually hdb
left over grass patch between the public
housing blocks
so nanyang poly came together with the
residence committee
and co-created a beautiful garden using
very cheap recycled materials
artistically curated so
you see there are actually many stories
like this and i start to realize that
when citizens love their cities it's not
going to be easily a grandiose skill
effort but they could be microscopic
by any city scale yet when you
accumulate them
actually they make wonderful collection
of stories
human stories i think that's really what
we need to uncover more
sometimes we drive it by policy
sometimes we drive it by
incentives but there are times where
people actually show their love but just
that
it's not her that's all
thanks for carrying that alicia i think
anna has to leave for another prior
um appointment but thank you so much for
spending
this hour with us and i really
appreciate it so much
uh you have any any last words that you
want to say to our audience and the
panelists
before you take your leave well
um i think this is a really really
interesting topic and i thought about
many things here during the discussion
and in our
pre-discussions and one one perhaps term
to throw in there still is that
uh there's kind of the element of
time so is there an element of you know
attraction or there was here in the chat
somebody's asking about so the love at
first sight that there's that attraction
that
do you want to visit a city or go to a
city or
what do you feel about different places
of it but then on the the other coin is
the um
the kind of pool of power in finnish we
had two really good words there's like
veto voymer which is a sort of
poor power and then pitovome which is
keep power
so the power to keep so to want to stay
and live in a city or to you know you go
and study somewhere and then actually
you want to
stay and give back to that community or
you are a business who wants to set up
offices there or you want to invest
there or
as an individual invest some of your
time back to the community or give back
so
i think that's one one important aspect
that we haven't perhaps yet discussed
about um loving places so the kind of
pull power but keep keep power
and um and and i mean that
there will never be any like one unified
idea of a love for a place somebody's
asking in the chat about
um unlovable designs there
i mean in helsinki as well we have
regularly heated discussions about
and increasingly so perhaps about you
know which is the
most beautiful building or which is the
most
hated building in the city or things
like this and
and um i think they all kind of
tell about that people are really
interested in their cities
and they are interested in where they
live and those places and their
environments and that for me
is is like a fuel that we
we um we have the responsibility to
to work with and tap into that
and and uh somehow enable space for
those different voices
thank you for those last closing words
before you have to make your leave
hannah yeah
and i mean i am a true believer that
design is one one key way how we can
hand do that and and work to to to
tune into the people great
thank you so much um it was great having
you here
um we'll be in touch again all right
thank you very much and i wish
all the luck with the lovable singapore
vision and look forward to seeing what
you have in there and continuing
discussions
with your great city that i have visited
once and very much loved
thanks i'm back okay bye-bye
have a good rest of the evening in
singapore
thank you okay bye-bye
okay so meanwhile um yes we'll continue
um i think there's some themes that
hannah brought up that
i don't know it sounds like material for
webinar three maybe design singapore is
to organize a third one
um sorry we were talking about making
this tangible right
lisa was sharing a bit of an example and
we were
talking about designing big and small
about scale and i think kelvin you were
going to say something about that
yes um okay so as a conservationist
i work with both big buildings and small
buildings but
what i found for the public
it's not so much whether it's a big
building a small building um
i think we talked about the new national
library that's really huge and the old
the old queenstown library that's very
small in queenstown
and the queenstown library is my library
i grew up in queenstown that's
my library to me right that's my library
and and i thought actually what's
what is something we can make tangible
more in singapore with regards to
love whatever skill it's the idea that
we have to get involved in this
in these discussions you know it's not
just about what
is being kept or what's not to be kept
but it's what do we do with the city
around
us do we wish to participate um
and if we should participate are there
structures and systems in place to allow
for participation
you know because this is so important
because if we have
uh clearer and more soft as we develop
more sophisticated systems for
um participation dialogue hearing from
each other
i believe that this is then we can
really garner garden and love
so just this past weekend we had a
distribution of moon cakes for seniors
in this neighborhood someone had donated
moon cakes for seniors
and my i'm involved in the grass roots
in kyung bao ramen residence committee
and because this estate hasn't got
lifts it's very challenging to visit 500
flats
with 20 people to this case so we did
something new we use
facebook to say recall we have this
thing to do who wants to come and help
and i was so impressed we were so
humbled that more than 20
new individuals came to help us because
they wanted to do something for cheong
baru
they most of them lived around chiang
mai across the road across the market
and they brought their husbands their
wives their children so to me that's
expression of love
first jiangbao meant something for them
and number two they wanted to express
and then number three there was a system
for them to participate
and now the challenge for me as a in the
neighborhood committee is
how do i keep them close to us to say
what makes it meaningful for you to want
to continue to participate
in other parts of the neighborhood in
its future right
so so i think people want to participate
because they understand that things take
time
and if they can participate about this
about futures creation
i think that can engender love um as
lisa said there are many things that
happen
we don't see it before i moved in here
our new young borough was beautiful as
art deco
after being here for 15 years i realized
that some of my neighbors who really
love this place because it's their
memories
and they want to make sure they can do
something it can be planting a garden
it can be sweeping the street it can be
coming out to talk to a neighbor
so many little acts of love but we need
to start designing systems where people
can really
participate but i also feel that scale
is
is not to be overlooked as a designer
i chose to live in kyungbao in singapore
because of my experience of a student in
london
on the port by low road i had never
lived in a low rise environment before
but suddenly i realized that when you
have that one street
and everyone walks at one street every
day you can see faces
you recognize faces over time it's the
same few faces
that can be a prerequisite for you to
say hello how are you
are you new around here or i will go to
the one coffee shop and you make a
relationship
so the human skill is so important
because it can
allow for people to start knowing each
other as individuals
so as designers how do we factor in this
micro scale
in the skill of a gigantic city
yeah there's a lot of things to think
about from a design perspective right
and i'm just starting to get a sense
that
it's possible if you start to really
take note of all these little things
like you mentioned about
the layering of not just the physical
environment but the people who live in
it right the emotional connection
uh we'll talk about the size uh i think
previously we also talked about the
ability to
to have eye contact across the street um
previously mentioned about other
seemingly unsexy acts of love right we
were talking about that like
providing lifts and ramps
yeah you want to elaborate on that a bit
more
well i was going to say that uh
sometimes we think about trying to
create lovable cities and we try too
hard we organize events
we make it unnatural for people to
express their love
and you you can only last that long you
know one event two events how many can
you do per year
so i think love has got to be intuitive
it has to be natural
uh as natural as as the kevin said go to
the corner coffee shop sit there
interact with your neighbor something
you would do every day
and you need to make those experiences
wonderful
lovable rather than try to create events
after events of the events they won't
last
so same thing with i mean kevin you talk
about the portobello
street being linear what about a
vertical street our live lobbies are
absolutely functional and transactional
there's no feeling in it because of
sorry floor area constraints and
all that stuff right the same with rams
it has so straight and
poor physically challenged people
just got to climb it like a mountain
there's no love no feeling in it
so every day things we take it for
granted but if our designers if our
planners and even policy makers think
about making use of every little
opportunity
to create spaces for human interaction
human love of expression and just enjoy
everyday life i think the city will
transform itself
remarkably so thank you so that at least
i mean just jumping here the small
things right one thing that really
frustrates me
that really frustrates me is how
we don't have people who know about the
art of placing benches
to sit and to enjoy a beautiful view
that really hurts me
i need a chief bench officer in
singapore to deal with pictures
[Laughter]
what can the designers listening to this
do then right i mean we will talk about
benches we talk about uh designing
opportunities for memories so
i mean what's the big shift that needs
to happen in the design scene i mean
we are talking about design now right
what's that one shifted that you feel is
the
core of it is there any
in fact well if i could just build on
something that kelvin and
lisiang have been talking about which is
the idea of small
right i think um sometimes
design can be seen as and not always i
know as we're as practitioners we are
prob we are quite familiar with this
it's not always the big lofty thing
it is the call the accumulation or the
combination of many many small things
over time so if you think about small
times many
equals big right a very simple equation
something like that
but you go the the most small pockets
you try and design and the more you try
and connect the dots
the more cohesive the big picture will
be you just have to know what you're
driving towards
yes we are ultimately driving towards
livability
uh but you can't really design for love
ability you have to break
loveability down into into much much
smaller pockets to think about
so what are the series of briefs that
you we would want to put out there
how do you get private and public to
to come together a lot more it's not
even just it's not
these days it's not just fully the
public or private sector whose
responsibility it is
but you're trying to you're trying to
you know
have that blend where you can actually
move towards a common goal together
and actually there was one other thing i
didn't want to address because i do love
a lot of things that lisang and calvin
have brought up about
over time and we are looking back at how
things have grown but i think
um looking forward it would be really
remiss of us to not address the current
situation
and the pandemic and what that has what
that has
that upheaval that has caused our
all of our lives right where that
boundary between
work and home is completely blur
and our homes were not made for four
people imagine you've got two twenty
something year children at work
or even in school with home-based
learning and two working parents in
their forties
the hdb flat is not made for you to work
for four people to be on con calls all
day long
you know so those boundaries and what we
do from here on out and how
and you know honestly when then when i
got like the
the what is it called i could delay my
income tax payments and i got like the
hand
i felt very patriotic i was the first to
admit i felt that i was like wow
that's great no other government in the
world can make this happen this fast
right but it's it but i think
actually people and if i can phrase this
in kind of a
in a very soft way i think right now in
this time people are looking to be held
in a different way right they're looking
where
everything has shifted how what does
that mean for the design of our homes
what does that mean for the
relationships that we forge
if we're going to be spending so much
time not traveling
into the city for where that boundary is
now blur what does that mean for the
shops that exist
under our homes do we bring it back do
we
you know uh create i mean for the
longest time
if you and i and i'm only just quoting
from experience
many people talk about the elusive
kampung spirit and how we've lost it
and we designed our way out of it
unintentionally
i think we may have and what's the way
to bring it back and i think right now
is the opportunity to ask what's going
on at home
at work where do you need
support and how can that be designed so
i think that is i think there's a huge
opportunity i think to to move
down a long-term small initiative sort
of
uh helping people cope in a much in a
much
better and more sustainable way than is
for example
a sum of money which i'm very thankful
for but may not
necessarily build up the lovability that
we're talking about today
yeah i'm glad you brought it up because
even for for my own practice right we've
been thinking
about this a lot how covet this whole
era that we live in affects the way we
design spaces the way we we kind of
create opportunities for relationships
to thrive and i think that idea of
the neighborhood scale is becoming so
important right like we don't think
about like say
travel to the city we really just like
go to a neighborhood shop right the idea
of a local business
uh that we support uh even if you use an
app to get food delivered there's still
a radius that you have to engage with
right so that that idea of smallness and
neighborhood scale
at least in my mind kind of coincides
quite well with this opportunity that we
have to
design for levelability in a very
strange and
way that we've been given this
opportunity to work on that
um yeah i mean how about nissan and
kelvin any thoughts like
how do you think covey will really
affect the way we design for this
levelability
well i really don't think that we need
to build ourselves uh
built the case around kobe this problem
existed
centuries and still going we need to
fundamentally address
why our designers think the way they
think and
re-examine or rather restore
the values of design that is really for
human being for society
go to schools architectural school
design schools and actually start
questioning what are they focusing on
is aesthetics or is it just engineering
technology
are there any schools that pride
themselves to say we designed for a
human being
we need to ask those hard questions and
then we need to start research
on lovable design a good design is one
possibility
lovable brings it sharper the focus and
if it's not enough uh
find some other name whatever that
schools are comfortable with
and do research take a walk a section
say you walk through orchard from ion
all the way to isana
start examining what part you love what
part you don't love and why
and same thing do with buildings to go
through the buildings
itself and say what part you love of
course you don't love and then start to
weed out all the things that you don't
love can you imagine the
overwhelming result at the end of the
day if we start knowing what is lovable
and then design those things i think you
totally transform singapore
thanks for talking about uh being quite
critical about our environment and what
we love and what don't love
and and i thought uh in this over
conversation with
we mentioned about time so i think when
we
start looking at designing for love we
should think about designing beyond the
physical
object what kind of systems are we
designing to facilitate
the object building space or space to
be born and what kind of systems and
mindsets must we design
such that these spaces can grow in the
city and grow old
you know because it takes time someone
said what if you love falling over the
plus side yeah
there's the good looking you see him or
her first side you fall in love
but the question is that will you want
to look at the same phrase for a long
time i think it's a test right
same for the city um where are the
spaces in city that we really love and
then what are those qualities beyond the
physical
you know one of the
two of the spaces in the city that we've
been involved in protecting as a
conservationist
would be heritage sites in some way or
the other one is kavanaugh bridge
and the other one is this the padang
right it's a space not really protected
but we know it's going to be there for a
long time
and and in the entire city of 700 square
kilometers these two small spaces they
are so small
and yet they're so powerful not because
they are beautiful
but because everyone has been there at
some point in their life
they've been there when they're happy
they've been there when they're sad
they've been there with their
alone with their loved ones etc and it
hasn't changed
right so should we be designing for
sufficient spaces
of unchangingness in the city
that we can revisit visit and revisit is
number one
and then for the the kovite 19 or not
covet 19.
in this situation we are so local the
local shop the local business etc
we should be quite critical what is the
difference between the food court
run by multicult national versus hawker
center
or coffee shop is it that people
in the letter the coffee shop the hawker
center are really independent businesses
and they have a
relationship with you and me that's one
to one
in a city of 5 million people there are
100 people that know us we know them
you know so we have to go beyond the the
form
and to understand the dynamics of it
then if there's a crisis
we will have neighbors and shops who are
also our friends that we can call on
you know to support each other we need
to do it now
invest in the human
i'm just bringing up the the poll
results from the question
beginning right and so in the
runaway winners the idea of personal
memories and experiences makes a place
livable to our audience
second would be the idea of authenticity
and identity
and then the third one would be
possibilities for interaction and
connection
so it seems to be quite aligned with
what we've been talking about um
any of the finalists you want to comment
on
um let's comment the lowest one let's
comment the
aesthetically easy which is only comes
in at 16 percent do you think of this
one man's meat and a man's poison
it's good it's good i think at least we
are aligned
that is not the most important factor so
beauty is not
a prerequisite to lovability it helps it
helps to
it helps to make the first connection
maybe no maybe we have to redefine
beauty i mean
really it's a hard thing to define from
for buildings we can define for fashion
we can design or even that's tough
sometimes
but for cities um
[Music]
i think the beauty goes beyond skin deep
beyond just
surface aesthetics it's about skill that
we talk a lot about
it's about the coziness of
people's uh feeling comfortable with
each other
i i i mean i take for example rambla
in barcelona for me one of the most
beautiful street and it brought back a
lot of uh
beautiful memories and experiences and i
asked myself
my experience of taking portugal nowhere
near is
too dangerous to walk on not sure i mean
you cross the street you die
that to me is very fundamental right and
if you talk about beautiful orchard is
beautiful architecturally
but it doesn't give me any hopes you
know any stickiness of
for me to hang on to feels very
transactional
so i think those are the things we need
to do deeper
to ask ourselves uh is it as
is it really aesthetics i don't know i
think it's more than aesthetics
but agree personal memory and
experiences play a part
if you go to a place and you stop
remembering it i think there's something
wrong with that place
i only have about 10 minutes left before
we have to wrap our discussion so i just
want to
swing the other way instead of talking
about love love love let's talk about
heartbreak
there's a lot of people who have had
their hearts broken by the city
right oh i just don't feel love i don't
feel belong
or you talk about global citizen i'm not
a global citizen i'm stuck here
my spaces have been taken away from me
you know this is not the city that
i can live no matter what they build
right so let's talk about that um how do
we deal with this
idea of having your heart broken by the
city
anybody want to start
i think being humans we all experience
heartbreak in different ways in our
lives it is
a natural power life cycle
and i think in our relationship the city
is also the same and therefore
i would find it very
[Music]
sad if the entire city has no one
small place that a person can feel that
he or she
has ability to be loved in some way
because the city is this abstract thing
right it's down to what is the
um manifestation of that love and that
love may well be
may will be that neighbor who looks out
for you and and cares for you and that
is love in a way too
if the city allows for that relationship
to happen
then i think there is still the
possibility of love in the city just
that it's transformed into a human
relationship
right so i but sometimes you need to go
away
and come back i don't think i love
singapore so much until i went away
as a young man and then i realized oh
what i missed about it right
so those are things that we need to do
for ourselves and then to rethink
about what we think it's love and where
we can find it
or if we can't find it then the church
where can we make it
because i think we have a responsibility
also don't say i want to be loved
it's uh how can i show my love in some
way
it's a reciprocal relationship
yeah we were talking about designing
systems right to allow people to
participate and express their love
so maybe there could be a way to man
this heartbreak a little bit
uh lisan enabled some wisdom from you
about how could we potentially deal with
this heartbreak
yeah it's just thinking which city did i
break up with
well maybe i can think of beijing i went
there
as a young man in the 1980s
where hutongs are plenty beautiful
the courtyard houses are everywhere and
the cbd is
nothing really nothing i
really enjoyed that black and white
memory of it as we all know beijing has
a change
or transform in the 80s 90s i hated it i
really didn't want to go back there
because i saw so much destruction but
again it's debatable this is for growth
for economic growth
and it destroyed a lot of things and
then in the 2000s we see
crazy buildings come out in beijing i
don't like that too
to me it's uh overspending
but i went back there recently in 2010
15 or so it's not like it again i think
it shows that
the city planners are starting to
realize you can't have a city that is
designed to just resemble some other
cities
cultural elements come back with
nearly 20 million people there you have
to keep them happy
you know otherwise you have riots so
i think the city transformed itself very
top-down
unfortunately but i start to fall in
love again
with it because start to see human
spaces now very important is that uh
i just want to make a light point here
is that a city that
you fall in love with must have places
to sit
in a city that nobody sits down you
can't fall in love with
so totally agree the earlier point so
yep
singapore has many places still cannot
sit down
so that's the key right to to to make a
livable city we're gonna have proper
yeah how do you have a conversation with
the cities how do you have a
conversation with the people if you're
always rushing from point a to point b
and places to pause places to sit so an
entire bench project would be the first
project we should launch to make a
lovable city
maybe oh yeah romantic romantic benches
the bench where you want to go and
propose
the bench for the first date and the
bench for the date when you want to
like that because that's actually a real
question that came up in one of the q as
right like are we lacking in this kind
of spaces to allow love to happen
i think we lack enough people in the
system
who feel that this is part of their
remit
in their day-to-day work
who looks after love no one looks after
love right what gets measured gets done
so if love doesn't get measured love
doesn't get done i mean i'm very
practical about it so let's use the
pragmatic approach to our advantage
perhaps
we do need more babies
yes so they'll be in the budget paper to
justify
why we need more romantic sports
nishan how are you any thoughts on it
no about about banner i'm just thinking
about all the weirdly placed ventures
i've ever come across i've also think
thinking about all the justifications
that i've ever heard for not building
benches or more public spaces
singaporeans don't like the heat uh that
as in you know you've got the
i'm very curious about the you know
build it and they will come
does that does that does that does that
work i'm not sure
uh how do we test that and how do we how
do we use that as an
opportunity to learn how people want to
interact
right uh how how people want to interact
or change the way we interact i love
calvin's earlier point about you know
about livable city and
my association with that may just be
with my next-door neighbor
but but also with my neighborhood but my
but
basically my my idea of my city is that
and that can be enough um so to the
idea of just designing all these small
small pockets
singapore is already so small but you
can still make it even smaller
because um and when you break it down i
think um
that becomes so much more doable
almost designable easy easier not easy
at all
but easier than to grapple with this big
ambiguous
concept which is what love is big
ambiguous and cannot be controlled
and cannot be engineered and cannot and
very hard to measure
right um i was thinking more i was just
building on the
what the panelists were talking about
the bench to propose on
i i i like a city that is optimistic
like one that is built around a
narrative of hope
rather than fear i think these days
there is so much
fear and i thought about the wedding and
the the proposal and it made me smile
because i was like hey that's a really
hopeful forward-looking event
i want to stay here because i i can see
my future here
i i know that i can succeed here
no matter where i am and this i guess
yes i'm sure the built environment has a
place
uh has something to do with it but it's
the memories that are created or the
experiences within that
i was thinking about the i did a project
once and we interviewed
um a bunch of people who stayed in
novina
uh when the nearest mall is ue square i
say united square the one in all the
tuition centers
and then a very a very very funny quote
we got from the interview was
that is the saddest mcdonald's in
singapore
saddest mcdonald's in singapore because
you have a bunch of primary school
children under the age of 12
rushing their homework and that's the
only thing that they're going to
remember
this this mall and this mcdonald's for
but maybe mcdonald's all over singapore
has much happier memories
but that particular one is just i'm
rushing my homework in it
right so when we start to think about
those experiences
and and the associations of those
experiences
of having to of maybe not performing so
well in school
or wondering what your future looks like
i think there are all these things that
come into play that
i think can only start to and start to
be designed from
from looking at those individual
experiences and distilling common themes
of how we want to interact with each
other
how we want our future to look like
which we may not even know how to
articulate
we only can compare but we cannot really
articulate what it is we
we need some people may be um but i
think ultimately if
if singapore wants to be a lovable city
then the question we should be asking
ourselves is what kind of lover you want
to be
right like what what like you know are
you the i
do you want me to love you the way i
love my mother
don't know or my father my grandma oh
you want me to love you like my friend
or you want me to love you like uh my
partner
right which which which which love story
is it that you're gonna tell
or are we gonna tell each other or
accept common responsibility for
um i think those those things are great
questions to actually start to grapple
with
yeah i think i i love that question
right like no if singapore wants to be a
lovable city it has to ask
what kind of level does it want to be
maybe it needs to be
a few maybe just to focus on just one or
two
right you might mean different things to
different people um
but it's a very important question
because that kind of accepts the tone
about
how we design how we design everything
right from the environment
or policies to communicating the systems
to enable people to participate which we
talked about as well
um to the decision-making process right
because that sets
a mental framework for us to say i am
this type
of city and this is how i'm gonna show
my love to my citizens or
or to each other right this has been a
very wonderful conversation
i think we have there's a lot more q and
a on the document that i've been sent
but we are running out of time so we
can't answer all but i'm just gonna pick
one quick one
and see
let's see okay so there's this one right
livable spaces don't necessarily
translate to profitable spaces
how do we deal with that i mean life can
be expensive you know
love is love is expensive love is
expensive just not can be
love is expensive
yeah i know this is a singaporean
problem
everything must be written with return
on investment
so back to my earliest point which is uh
what you love your sustain so i think
looking beyond the dollar
census how do we sustain this country
how do we sustain
the social economic and environmental
aspect of singapore i think that
singaporean will understand so you need
unfortunately uh fortunately we need to
give
our people a reason to love
if you don't give any reason to learn
i'm afraid we are not going to manage
this very easily
you may excite people for a moment
but they're not going to be any roadmaps
so instead of profitability i substitute
with the word sustainability
i think that's a lot more holistic yes
the purist may not like it the theory
still like to say
love is love no if no but but
here i think we need to link my view
link love to sustainability but very
broadly
about sustaining this nation and our
people
so that would be how our attacker
i i agree with lisang um i think
when it comes to spaces um knowing that
the city is any country faces uh
economic pressures and the market right
the market's going certainly at the
moment
therefore our duty as uh i would say
planners and managers of city
must be such that we find ways to
safeguard
if not the private spaces that people
love at least
the civic spaces that we have in our
country
are there enough of them are they
suffering well designed located and
managed
such that people can continue to have
them as a resource
for expressing love in whatever way
because at the end of the day
humans one of my former bosses always
said you know
as a planner or conservationist um
what are you giving our young men who go
to ns or reservists when they're older
when push comes to shove what reason are
we giving them to say i will stay and
fight for this place
instead of running away that was a
question that really shocked me because
yeah actually every day
if people don't love this place why
would they stay because the human
condition is also to flee and escape and
survive
so to want to stay and to defend your
turf
is very irrational in a way and we're
talking about irrational feel
irrational feelings when it comes to a
country so we'll end the day we have to
ask ourselves
what is it to love singapore singapore
is too abstract we must go down the
scales is it because i love my
neighborhood
my community i love my school i love my
church temple mosque i love my neighbor
i love my street
i love my friends and the city must have
a system to maintain all those
requirements for love to be distilled
down
at various scales then i think singapore
can sustain itself
without love singapore is finished so we
must
find a way to sustain the love
i'm going to try and answer the question
a bit hit a bit head on mostly because
of my experience
in working with a lot of private sector
organizations as well where
uh if you just talk about perhaps some
real estate clients who run who runs
who who holds the most power in in real
estate
right the people that lease the states
the people who
who who charge rent for space so
um and it works at the minute you can
will it work forever
don't know which is why i completely uh
i'm on board with this idea of what
sustainability looks like but when i
think about design
i also think you can design a building
you can also design a business
businesses right now are designed to for
example to to collect to collect rent
because it works that's the dna of the
company and because it works
what are some of the more innovative
design
of innovatively designed businesses
that go into co-funding that go into
investing into your into your small
business
that uh would that actually wants to be
in your that actually wants to be in
your mall
but cannot afford the rent for example
um
what does what does that what does that
look like um
and it it goes so many ways right like
how can all those things be designed at
the start it's a very complex exercise
but i truly believe that
um businesses can be designed
as much as buildings can be the
environment can be designed and i think
the earlier those two disciplines come
together
to discuss what that path to profit
looks like
instead of just being handed over a plan
with a series of boxes to sell
the faster we will solve that problem
now what we need to have is more
designers and business people that can
translate between those two worlds
to be able to talk about what like this
is the need that we see and the common
language of the people
and those needs that you need to design
for are the things designers and
business people
we joke often you don't have that much
in common and when you try when you come
to the table
you are more negotiating rather than
collaborating
right but what does collaboration
between people of many different
disciplines look like
and how do you respect where the other
is coming from so that we can
design that future that we're looking
for
in i mean for to to the person who posed
the question you're absolutely right
and that if people if these companies do
not make profit and make money they are
gone
they are shareholders too they have
shareholders to answer to
right so those day-to-day demands are as
important
but i think and it's and it's the
perpetual problem
of changing the wheels of the moving bus
here's today but there's the future
that's the future and what does that
path to profit look like and as
and as early as we can get these
different disciplines to the table with
the same intention and a common language
the faster we'll get to solving this
problem
[Music]
yeah almost like we the idea of design
is to be really expanded for us to
tackle study
right to design it it's not just about
the buildings but the systems we're
talking about even the businesses
um right about how do all of these work
together
the various disciplines in order for us
to create
a sense of lovability and yet balancing
sustainability and profitability
um because maybe they are not mutually
exclusive ideas
right yeah thank you so much panelists
this has been wonderful i think there's
a lot of
questions that gonna come up and i think
for the audience uh dsg is gonna share
that this is just the beginning of this
journey about exploring this idea of
lovability
um just the two webinars there's a
survey that's gonna be uh
shared a bit more later on it's an
ongoing research and i think uh we're
gonna
hear from all of you and for those of
you who are watching this at a
later date the recorded version of this
i think
leave your comments or your questions in
the comment section and i'm sure your
design is a problem so take that
to for for further study all right so
once again thank you to all the
panelists
uh for spending your evening with us i'm
gonna pass the time back to janine do
you think you want to take back the
screen
thank you i did thanks panelists i'm
just gonna take like five more minutes
of your time to share with you
the upcoming public engagement that
we'll be running
so as promised uh we would like to now
open
officially our lovable singapore project
in nationwide study
and here is how you can participate so
over the next few months
we'll be running a series of public
engagements to
uncover what we love about singapore and
what will make us love singapore more
so through our early research and i
think the panelists sharing just now it
brought out very clearly
that lovability is a very important part
of helping us build stronger communities
societal resilience civic participation
and innovation
so your views will help us to uncover
and understand what a lovable singapore
could look like and how we can get there
and we hope these collective insights
will help us to
identify opportunities to run projects
and programs to make singapore more
lovable so only with diverse views and
feedback
can we create a robust and
representative study that can serve
singapore better
so here is how you can participate um
over the next few months there are these
lineups
of activities to engage you whether you
have 10 minutes or 30 minutes or 45
minutes
there are different activities you can
take part in to
have your voice heard and to give us
direct input into our research
so all the links to these activities can
be found
on our website which we are currently
putting in the chat box
below so let's say you have 10 minutes
then share a story with us through the
to me singapore is
story collection if you have a bit more
time
you can join the online show and tell
and use your mobile phone
to answer interactive multimedia
questions
with the videos and photos or if you
prefer to just speak to us directly
then sign up for our online copy talk
which is a virtual focus group
discussion
and games session so here's a qr code
again
and the dates and registration links
will be
will be there on our website
yeah and really hope uh to hear from you
and
uh to to be able to get all your diverse
views
uh another point is that we will be
posting up the
answers to questions that were not uh
that we didn't manage to get
to uh during this q a so we'll be asking
our panelists to please uh
you know answer your questions and we'll
also be posting it on this website so
do look out for that so finally uh if
you could help us to complete a quick
post event survey which is on the qr
code on the left
oh sorry on on the right my mistake uh
we would love to hear your feedback on
today's session
and uh once again thank you i did thank
you lisang
calvin and hannah for the great
conversation and thank you to
all the attendees for spending your
evening with us
so good night and hope to see you soon
thank you thank you all
thank you safe keep well thank you bye
bye bye everyone
you